state your name for the record Wade
Barnes February 2018 the door blows off
the hinges something unexplainable was
going on dreaming never stops
is Molly dead I ran up those stairs
faster than I think I ever have or ever
will again
dripping in the basement dripping down
the window they're big never stops being
fan pouring out water at that point I
wasn't thinking of what could possibly
be haunting the house I was just
thinking of saving it it's not natural
here in your house the Gateway for some
greater evil to be born we thought that
it was all over what Molly and I didn't
know was that the real nightmare was
just beginning what can he do
where can he go from here who can he
turn to for help is it possible that no
one is around to help him oh yes more
possible than you think but the story
doesn't end just because no one is
around to hear it the story continues
the cruelty continues their watery
demise continues and it shall continue
until every mode of Hope is war
the night of January 31st into the day
of February 1st all of the damage was
done
water mitigation company was sent out we
thought was gonna fix everything they
brought in fans to dry out the ceiling
they punctured holes in the floor and
put tubes and dry out the walls and we
thought okay they'll give it a few days
and then you know maybe by the weekend
the following weekend February 8 they'll
be in here to repair everything February
8 just came and went February 16 the
22nd into March all the way into April
with no help in sight until April 15th
finally salvation was at hand someone
was here to put all of this behind us or
so we thought
when they showed up we felt their
incompetence from the start it was a
little weird
that they weren't replacing the drywall
basically the vibe I got was well
anything could be fixed with enough mud
that didn't seem quite right so true to
their word mud was a solution they
scrape it all along the seam and they
gave it a day to dry they came back the
next day with a slightly bigger piece of
metal scraped it along the seam gave it
a day to dry now I've been told this is
standard procedure for how mudding works
the problem was they were mudding bad
drywall all said and done they wrapped
up the final layer of mud on a Friday
night on a Thursday I'm sorry and then
on Friday they came in and they sanded
it down toward the point where they
could paint and they told us Monday they
would come in they'd spend about 4 or 5
hours painting and they'd be done
finally finally this would be done and
then the crack started for me on Monday
morning they showed up they looked at
the ceiling and the cracks in the
ceiling and they said well maybe it
needs more mud we gave up on this
company being confident we called some
people that had already come to our
house and worked on stuff in the past
and we told them what was going on and
the first thing they said was do they
replace the drywall
no they didn't replace the drywall so
while we're waiting on the other company
be able to come in and help us we had an
event going on pivot so gore and I and
Marie and Ellie we all arrived at Wade's
house I believe it was early Thursday
morning
we got there before the whole rest of
the group got there we were all there
pivot may 17th I believe was the day we
had to call plumber into the house
because that toilet also would not fly
we ended up using the restroom and I
noticed that the toilet got backed up so
I mentioned to wave believe the next day
that the plumber ended up coming out I
believe he said it was something like a
piece or some of the part of the chain
inside the toilet wasn't fixed
regardless the plumber said that should
all be good but that toilet and this
house were far from done with us so I
get there Friday evening toilets working
fine and no issues again I'm sleeping
directly under this toilet may 18th I
found this out later
JP who's staying with us woke up opens
his eyes stretches looks at the ceiling
and says to himself hmm
is that yellow ring supposed to be there
I wake up and there is a huge water
stain on the ceiling I mean I'm not
talking like a little bit of a water
damage girl I'm trying to make an actual
bubble that was a little bit sinking in
the middle but rushing to get ready so
he would be late to the event he
neglected to mention it to me until
later that night and I don't know if
it's coincidence or irony or what to
call it but we decide to celebrate a
good day out by watching scary stuff on
TV
top five horror this top 5 haunted this
and as we wrapped up and all got ready
for bed
JP turned on the light in his room and
not only was there a yellow ring on the
ceiling but the ceiling was sagging and
he said oh yeah I meant to tell you
about that earlier kind of forgot but uh
I think there's something wrong I
completely forget to tell him honestly
my bad on that probably should have told
him so upon seeing
a very familiar sighted of a water
damage ceiling and I felt around the
yellow portion to see if it was still
dry or wet waves like on my air mattress
trying to feel it but he's only touching
the outside
JP decided to do the same thing but
instead of feeling around with his hand
he took a single finger and went right
for the center of the ring and then he
just bounced on his bed and Boop I go
right for the middle because that's just
what I do water is just flowing out and
I am just sitting there taking it I do
not question life at that moment the
house soiled all over him we all just
stood there shocked I was probably
standing there pretty easily like 10
seconds just letting water flow on me
all over its bed all over all of his
possessions but thankfully this time it
spared the floor I guess there was a
bright side for us but not for poor JP
it didn't smell terrible I thought it
was clean however it turns out it was
actually really pretty water yeah it was
the only thing I could think of is why
why what what is doing what is causing
this what bad karma did I bring what
could be doing this to us
I sent said there was some other problem
nearby everywhere kitchen sink had to be
replaced that bathroom was a mess the
room right is a greater problem lies in
that room man yeah this I guess will
walk over there also hi there I I
haven't said anything to you since
you're just holding the camera don't
look at them okay
are you professional or not no I'm just
uh this was the air mattress that my
friend was on someone got shocked right
here yeah the ceiling had a big ring on
it and we felt around it I felt around
it and the yellow part was dry but it
was still like a white bulging Center
and he put his finger right through it
and yeah he got shot on pretty badly
he's dead now isn't he anyway you don't
know any phone I was making sure he was
alive now is not the time to text okay
that still doesn't move well it was all
the toilets called this room got messy
that's why you got Shannon was boiling
way to fix Whalen or was it the people
on the toilet I mean Patrick could have
taken like a mammoth [ __ ] I guess and
broken pipe who's Patrick there's only
one possible way to get to the bottom of
this you have any candles I got like the
battery-powered kind I'm a little
battery-powered lantern you don't want
your real candles oh that's one of those
batteries right now real candles are
kind of expensive and we've spent a lot
of money on their batteries are kind of
expensive you know and they have
dangerous chemicals inside then that
caused problems for the we didn't can
these get a sustainable you know the
world's largest cable do you know how
long they would burn for I don't forty
years we didn't bother guys gonna run
out they were gave me a battery that
lasts
energizer like all the candles to keep
their battery candles
alright you're the lantern yeah there's
something back so this isn't it's no
longer cool so frozen pipes has yeah
Sunday we couldn't get anybody out so
Monday a plumber came in got another big
hole in the ceiling and that one of the
pipes was dripping that sometimes this
happens maybe some of the sealant around
where the two pipes connect wore off he
said he had to take the toilet off cut
out a section of pipe and replace it but
just like the first company that came
out to fix the ceiling the first attempt
to fix the pipe under the toilet wasn't
successful the very next day I have to
call the plumber again because the pipe
a little drop of water drips and another
drop of water and it drips
and I cannot stand the sight the sound
the thought of another drop but there it
was and I could not believe it so I
called them and I told them the pipe was
still leaking so they came out they cut
out the part of the pipe that they had
replaced and they replaced it again was
a different kind of pipe I'm not sure
the different terminology but for some
reason this was a more secure fix why
did they do that the first time I don't
know what is this Mario you stupid fool
it's no ancient Roman this is how we
commune with those the only way the
answers you seek mr. ass so my problem
stop it your hand off the knife then ask
stupid questions or you'll get answers
so by this time our friends are gone
tips over and the house is just Molly
and me and the pets we called our
friends who had fixed a built my office
for me done the repairs and they were
supposed to come and do the drywall in
not only for the living room now but for
the room JP had stayed in they came out
they wore out the drywall immediately
they said that I should have been done
the first time and they put up brand-new
drywall and after they're done
the painters supposed to come out nine
o'clock in the morning I opened the
double doors that lead into the room
where JP was staying and my heart
dropped again the ceiling was sagging
there was a dark grey line several of
them and there was a drip and a drip and
another one and a big wet spot on the
carpet again so all the painters worked
on the living room I had the same
plumbing company come out not the first
time not the second time
not even the third time but a fourth
time and this time they came out they
cut a hole in the ceiling the pipe was
[ __ ] they walk up the stairs they
look at the toilet
till it whose enters they'd worked on
the very first time they came out
somehow some way the bolts there are
three bolts and the big tanga sits on
the back of the toilet those bolts had
come loose and water was dripping from
the tank of the toilet onto the floor
and seeping into the floorboards into
the wall and haunting us yet again on
the main floor what will it take for you
to leave
[Music]
top cost for tacos this is this isn't
working
just think of her yes or no this will
you leave without the tacos fast-forward
all the way to June 8 now from
everywhere first June 8th our company
comes out to built my office and they
start ripping out the drywall and
finally as they're ripping out the old
and putting in the new the pieces are
finally being put back together and
while the inside of our house is being
put back together the outside decided to
go on a fold-out rebellion June 18th the
day before our painters are scheduled to
arrive
Molly yells for me runs into the woman
and says you need to come see this
preparing myself for yet another
disaster in the house I follow her but
she doesn't go to a ceiling she doesn't
go to a room she goes to a window and
when I looked out the window I'd seen a
sight I have never seen before nor do I
expect to ever really see again I've
never seen a whirlpool form in your
Street attacked from all sides no escape
nowhere to run the very elements
themselves are setting themselves
against this poor soul needs to be done
can any of us help them yes actually we
can help indeed here I have the designs
of a very special t-shirt a
commemorative moment in Wade's suffering
for us all to remember this sordid tale
by purchasing this shirt not only will
you immortalize the moment of his peak
suffering but also all proceeds will go
to help this poor sod in paying for a
new roof and new pipes and a new toilet
and a new bathtub
she needs a lot of new things everything
seems to be infested with demons frankly
he should probably just burn the whole
house down and then start over fresh but
considering that's probably not an
option at least we can remember this
moment forever
[Music]